con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de lo que ocurre dentro
de Rusia en medio de la guerra con
Ucrania en los últimos anuncios del
presidente Vladimir putina que se debe
además el éxito de la contraofensiva
ucraniana pues lo vamos a hablar con
Alberto hutchen Roy 13 doctor en
relaciones internacionales autor de
numerosos libros sobre geopolítica
Alberto Gracias por estar esta mañana de
jueves con nosotros en directo América
de Francia 24 hagamos primero un balance
general de la guerra hasta ahora el
éxito de esta contraofensiva ucraniana y
como esto afecta también a Rusia no lo
vimos por los anuncios recientes del
presidente Vladimir Putin
hay una primera vía ataques Hace tres
semanas podemos hablar de ataques por
parte de Ucrania en el norte este de es
el territorio de
su territorio Pero hoy ya diría que son
contragolpes No es cierto y e incluso
establece recuperar personas como ha
pasado en los últimos en los últimos
días yo diría que lo que está pasando en
el escenario de guerra en Ucrania es que
han finalmente se han incrementado y han
comenzado a dar resultados las Los
Fuertes suministros que
proporciona occidente particularmente
Estados Unidos piense solamente que
Estados Unidos
proporciona el 60% de la ayuda militar a
Ucrania esto implica para Estados Unidos
unos 15 mil millones de dólares y en ese
suministro han tenido particular
resultados sistemas que vulneraron que
logra matar las defensas rusas por
ejemplo o en los sistemas de radares de
defensas rusas esto es clave Y de alguna
manera esto ha generado una situación de
incremento de la voluntad de lucha del
pueblo ucraniano y aparecieron alguna
evidentemente algunos problemas
relativos con la logística relativos con
el número la cantidad de soldados para
Rusia que desde ahora para mí va a
intentar hacerse fuerte en las zonas que
ha conquistado esto es la región del dos
más puede haber Entonces digamos una
retoma con ese llamamiento del
presidente ruso blademir Putin a 300.000
reservistas para que vayan entonces a
luchar a Ucrania debido si se puede
llamar de alguna manera el
debilitamiento de las tropas de Rusia
por lo que en otras cosas lo que dijo
usted pues este equipamiento militar de
occidente que ha ayudado a Ucrania a
defenderse con fuerza
sí totalmente es así ese es el panorama
de la guerra hoy no significa que
Rusia esté siendo derrotada cuidado tal
vez el objetivo principal de Rusia en
esta guerra haya sido precisamente
controlar la zona que controla que es
una zona muy importante es la región más
rica de Ucrania pero claro se le están
presentando problemas relativos
particularmente con con la cantidad de
soldados pero también con la vetustestes
de su doctrina militar Esta es una
doctrina militar que ha sido reformada
pero que es herencia de la época
soviética y tiene el punto de gravedad
fuerte en los sistemas de artillería es
decir en las rupturas en la destrucción
es romper el frente enemigo Y esto es lo
que ha venido haciendo Rusia pero con
como consecuencia de los nuevos
suministros de particularmente en los
últimos tres meses que ha recibido
Ucrania Ucrania ha impactado en los
sistemas particularmente de artille
perdón de artillería de Rusia por lo
tanto yo diría que hay un avance por
parte de Ucrania
Alberto Pues yo le quería preguntar
sobre problemas internos que pudiera
tener en este momento Vladimir Putin
digamos no sé dentro de su gobierno
dentro de la cúpula militar ayer también
quiero sacar a colaciones en este
espacio pues estas declaraciones fuertes
y contundentes del presidente Vladimir
Putin yo creo que desde que comenzó la
guerra pues no lo había visto digamos
tan amenazante sobre todo con el tema
nuclear dijo pues que tuvieran a cuidado
que recién iba a escatimar digamos a la
hora de defenderse a la hora de defender
sus ideales y su territorio y pues habló
de que este Arsenal nuclear desde Rusia
o cualquier arma nuclear podría entonces
mirar a occidente haciendo referencia
Obviamente con todos estos países
europeos que están apoyando Ucrania y
países de la otan
estoy mal no se preocupe Alberto
tranquilo Muchas conferencias estos días
mire lo que está pasando Es que
efectivamente Hay un problema con la con
el personal pero acá voy a hacer una
arriesgar un escenario que puede estar
detrás de la decisiones de Putin en
función de lo que usted acaba de decir
sobre el discurso
Quizá lo que busca Rusia a partir de
ahora es incorporar estos territorios
que controla al territorio de la
federación rusa para ello quizá se
produzca una suerte de escenario como
que como el que pasó Ni que inclinéa
referendo no es cierto que lleven estos
territorios a la soberanía o la
incorporen a el territorio de Rusia esto
nos va a detener la voluntad de lucha de
Ucrania pero si es así si estos
territorios pasan a ser parte de la
federación rusa entrarían dentro del
sistema de reserva mayor militar de
Rusia que son las armas nucleares y este
ya nos lleva a un escenario que no
conocemos bueno el objetivo sería un
poco Este no es cierto tratar de que se
repita en el don Bass lo que ha pasado
en Ucrania en 2014 por ejemplo es muy
lejos también quería ahondar en ese tema
porque así digamos comenzó de alguna
manera esta guerra en Ucrania está más
reciente en el dombasa no cuando se
declararon pues repúblicas
independientes Daniels y lugares y le
pidieron entonces pues ayuda a Rusia
Rusia entonces ahí si ya inició como
fuerza está intervención militar que
llama el kremlin invasión que lo llama
occidente pues En definitiva un
conflicto militar bien grande que está
ocurriendo en ese territorio Entonces
esto no sería también una estrategia una
táctica de Vladimir Putin para anexar
Entonces estos territorios e irse con
toda la fuerza militar contra Ucrania
digamos en ese en ese en esos
territorios para poder pues tener el
control total
Bueno es un escenario es un escenario No
es cierto Rusia en este momento
podríamos decir que está
fortaleciendo sus defensas porque lo que
se viene ahora Tal vez tal vez sea la
parte más peligrosa de la guerra porque
evidentemente se nota que Ucrania ha
incrementado su voluntad de lucha y por
otro lado han aumentado los suministros
no solamente de Estados Unidos que es
quien más proporciona suministros sino
Francia Alemania por ejemplo suministros
claves para golpear en los sistemas de
alerta o de defensa de Rusia y
particularmente en la clave de bóveda de
esta guerra de Rusia que es el sistema
de artillería el problema que Rusia
podría reaccionar aplicando una doctrina
militar que se conoce informalmente como
la doctrina grossni no cierto la
doctrine consiste en romper todo
destruir todo Por eso digo que la guerra
podría Entrar en este momento en una
fase mucho más peligrosa No es cierto